okay no I'm gonna go with arguments
grooming gangs is a Muslim is an Islamic
problem let's suppose suppose I'll
switch over here I'm just gonna make
this very clear what do they tend to use
to get them in alcohol lies they justify
it when I say it's believed is funnier
they use drugs they use alcohol they
have sexual intercourse yes yes okay now
I just want to make this something very
clear how Co is one of the major sins of
it's not you know not just Haram we have
major sins yeah yeah alcohol is one of
the major sins in Islamorada feeling
having sex having sex having sex outside
of marriage let alone rape but those is
one of the major sin in Islam yeah lying
is a major sin in Islam
so let me get this right Islam says
you're not allowed to drink alcohol you
are not allowed to rape you are not
allowed to lie
you know allowed to deceive
yes okay can you show me one instance of
grooming gang scene we knew these girls
because the Koran said that the fire
yeah there was some there was a fella a
justified his actions okay with and
you're gonna dispute as well please show
me okay please show me one grooming got
why swear I would that he said I mean
these girls because the Prophet Mohammed
his opponent married I shall to show me
and even even for argument's sake even
if he did it's a knife even if he did I
don't believe there is no you're missing
the point here the sex sexual
exploitation is not just grooming guns
there's a massive that's prostitution
yeah that's pedophilia a majority of our
white men I don't go around saying these
Christian white men pedophiles yeah and
the funny the funny thing is they accuse
us all your prophet was a pedophile okay
let's say for argument's sake no problem
yeah I would have been liar you claim
that the father was a pedophile why are
you guys doing it why is the 90 percent
of pedophiles are white men let's
suppose our religion our prophet teaches
us to do this for some reason we don't
do it what you do makes perfect sense
there is no way any of this grooming
these these combats who will ever use
Islam because they want they do it is
against Islam you drink an alcohol let
me tell you something
and why do not shake females hands
because it's not permissible I'm not
allowed to touch your hand I'm gonna
rape her how does that work economy in
touch your hand I'm not gonna rape
someone back to touch a hand
[Music]
Christian Harry Harry
you've made let me taste something here
I will see to do something here instead
of watching Tommy Robinson 24/7 educate
Harry Harry the way you're talking I
feel like I'm speaking to turn Robinson
you know what because no disrespect to
you because hurry the stuff that you
seen even when I clarified versus the
stuff you still staunch and Adam enough
no no no because if you was mothers
brothers brothers don't know excuse him
no excuses a songs telling you well I
believe you I believe you I believe you
just be quiet I don't know your heart I
don't know your heart I take your word
for you so hurry all I'm saying is keep
this mind frame and learn about Islam
from Muslims if you want to learn about
Judaism you're not gonna go to hit I'm a
not Muslim youtuber okay but why don't
you watch my stuff above a manatee job
okay
have you seen me inside hate have you
ever and these grooming grants as I said
here well done am i against them I'm not
I'm against them so can you not come and
say look at alia see hold on a second so
what's different against this different
with this Muslim but the rest why is he
saying something else stood up soon
whoever sees I know it's cold and you
got snow in here what I would say it was
if there's anything else you wanna add
on you can feel it Oscar but Harry
please I urge you keep your mind open
yeah
learn about anyone trying to say yeah
yeah yeah so I don't see this tab
because if you know you know what's
gonna happen you can end up being a
tomorrow Manson yeah someone that's full
of hate and inside hate and people take
those words or more than one Muslims
over if the word Muslim was changed to
Jew if Tony Robinson the amount of times
he mentions Muslims if that word is
change did you would have been locked up
it would have been the janazah night
night like we're here every Sunday here
come on there's no problem fast cuz come
and see Ali look I'm curious yeah I've
seen I'm here at your service you can
trying to sell you whenever you like I'm
here hopefully on a sunny day yeah yeah
and come and ask me questions yeah and
hopefully that's answered a
misconception operationally